awesome look boss
you
you
you
snake posh that's right
it's her what about the bomb we were
able to remove the explosives both of
them bomb no no no it's okay there's
another way
it's alright we got it out the guided
tour will be wrapped up by the time you
get home make me proud
by the time they leave I'll have the
iaea
praising us as the poster boys for world
peace something's not right check her
again
boss
it's okay yeah the bomb we mentioned
she hit the water hard and somehow she
managed to survive anyway the shock
triggered some kind of amnesia
make where's professor Galvez
you mean yeah she still thinks it's 1974
she's got no memory of anything before
that either cipher the KGB nothing it
looks to be a kind of dissociative
disorder dissociative amnesia where
memories are blocked out to protect the
line and dissociative identity disorder
whole personality changes what we're
seeing seems to be a combination of the
two she truly believes she's nothing
more than a student living in 1974 peace
day was a lot of fun I hope we can do it
again she doesn't respond to anything
that conflicts with her internal
timeline doctors pretty sure she's not
faking it
if she had her memory just think what
you could tell us about cypher
the photo is from that guy you brought
back the other day from the old crew I
thought it might jog her memory but no
luck
anything else you can show her do you
have something to show me snake
I give up she's all yours
hmm